[Music]
these apparently and maybe we'll figure
out why but anyway here's the first one
right here coffee table book nobody
wanted it
it's beautiful photos ruined by
douchebags absolutely gorgeous panoramic
views ruined by incredible d-bags yeah
oh god yeah there's that guy for me and
then I was just looking at the back and
man I think that's your 70 and then
here's a beautiful couple and then who's
this guy all right here's one didn't
sell apparently I got this for next to
nothing it's a common table book Joe
Biden in the movie ghost that's a
bargain yeah this one nobody wanted
Barry isn't that broke remarkable scene
I remember when Joe Biden was all yeah
here he is again
looking up go time ago he talked for two
hours I'm good ghost yeah anyway this
one didn't sell at all you know you hear
the first line and you think others
gonna be sexy and then hardcore pouring
shot from space it's not the same
there's a missionary position right
there
over here reverse cowgirl
threesome yeah that's not doing it for
ya yeah I just saw porn and I grabbed it
right look at this one right here it's
things Lindsay Lohan hasn't hit with her
car yet the Mars Curiosity rover hasn't
hit that yet still fine
yeah she hasn't yet hit the Stanley Cup
Jim didn't Brooklyn Carter
there they are and this Komodo dragon
apparently she did get the other Komodo
dragon oh well yeah what are you gonna
do that's too bad look at this one
nobody wanted this and this guy is a big
star people really like this guy they
didn't want this book Anderson Cooper
180 you know they just no one wanted
that it seems like would be a good idea
now and no one no no one apparently
wanted it well it's mine now sighs
here's one didn't go sex tips of the TSA
it just didn't
I know I know
and because you've reacted that way I'm
going to show you even more
Wow increased now somebody's got a very
open-minded coffee table exactly
this is one's weird it's my favorite I'm
keeping it it's the last one but it's my
favorite it's birds that murder I just
murdered yeah you know he did it that
hurt and then these guys really look
guilty
[Applause]
I would strain I was strained it was a
frame jobs all right